okay it is close to 245 we're gonna get
started
I
please to introduce to you James Powell
I first met James Powell when he was
giving his generator showcase showdown
talk I believe at a strata at a strata
and at the time he was working for
bammel and they were who knows what
bammel is make of America Merrill Lynch
there right off there they doing some
really progressive things with Python
have over 3000 Python developers but he
was working for bammel at a time
and he got me giving talks on best
practices and so since then I've I've
given a few talks at the Python meetup
group and had a - twice at PI Gotham and
so I really owe a lot to James and he
has since given talks on compiling
Python two and three together quite
impressive he's also known for his bad
puns and one-liners and now he will
address the the issue of the century I
think does code quality really matter
please welcome James Powell
Thank You Aaron for that very thoughtful
and heartfelt introduction so the title
of this talk is does code quality really
matter we're at PI data in New York it's
Wednesday November 11th 2015 and I'm
James Powell there's a reason I say that
because there are some people who are
seeing this talk some point in the
future on YouTube so it kind of helps to
know where this talk is being presented
and what the data is everybody looks at
me like I'm crazy when I say that out
loud
so hi I'm James so that's actually not
as bad as I thought it would be but try
one more time hi I'm James even better
so this is one of the last talks I'm
going to give this year this is a talk
that I gave this past weekend at PyCon
Canada the demo that I wanted to show
for the talk failed and when I tried to
resurrect the demo the backup demo
failed and then I had a third demo in my
back pocket which also failed and about
15 minutes into a 30-minute presentation
everything was going wrong it was an
absolute catastrophe I was so
embarrassed so I actually have PyCon
Canada on this schedule with the cross
out because didn't work out but
hopefully it'll work out a little bit
better for you and I rejiggered a couple
of things just to make this a little bit
easier or a presentation to give so I've
given a lot of talks this year this is
about the second to last talk I'm going
to give I'm really glad to be here at PI
down in New York this is the 12th PI
data event we've hosted in the 12th PI
that I've spoken at I think it's been an
amazing event so far
and I really like to thank all of you
for sticking around our program is not
quite over and I'd like if all of you
could stick around there's some really
cool lightning talks at the end of the
day so hopefully you'll all be able to
see those so you might wonder what on
earth are you doing if you're giving
talks at 12 conferences you some of
these are lightning talks but what on
earth might you be talking about and
Aaron mentioned a little bit about my
background but interestingly enough I
almost never talk about anything related
to the finance industry or data science
I usually give what I call avant-garde
talks and if you you know a little bit
about the avant-garde these are talks
which are intended to provoke and offend
the sensibilities thus if you go back to
the first slide my email address and my
Twitter handle
so bear in mind that you know I'm here
to be a little bit provocative now I'll
go into a little bit of a meta talk and
I'll show you why that works or why
that's might be important but before I
do that I want to show you a little bit
of a demo and it's a demo that sets the
story for what I'm going to talk about
it's not intimately related to this
topic but it's something that I want
well you know I just wanted to show you
go to this demo so some of you saw
lightning talks on Monday and on Monday
I showed off something that I was very
proud of that I put together at PI Texas
earlier this year it is one of my worst
and most gratuitous demos who saw who
saw the lightning talks so a bunch of
you what I was able to add to Python is
Reid watches and I showed you some
really horrible things you could do with
them just to start over or to show that
to you one more time you can import our
watch this is a module that can be pip
installed so let me just make sure in
this tab here import our watch and then
from the sis module I can just I can
create a variable sis that set up let me
create a function frame object print saw
object in right returned the object and
I can set a read watch on this so every
time somebody tries to access this
variable it'll trigger that custom code
and one thing that I left you with is
how on earth did I do this and the way
that I did this and some of the demos
that you can do with this horrible
horrible feature are actually quite
enlightening in trying to better
understand what software is how soccer
fits in how engineering works or trying
to get it maybe a slightly more
formalized or rigorous or mathematical
view of software so the way that I did
this is cpython
is a stack based virtual machine and in
that stack based virtual machine let me
go into my C Val dot C we have some or
actually in this virtual machine we have
some for loop that runs over all of our
op codes and for every op code it just
performs what the OP code would do so
one example would be binary multiply and
you can see when you try multiply
two things it pops two values off the
stack it multiplies them together and it
sets that back onto the top of the stack
well every time you try and perform an
operation on some variable in Python it
has to be on the stack somewhere and you
can see there are these macros pop and
top so what if I just went into the
macro we have to start at the beginning
the macro for pushing something onto the
stack and added some custom code there
so every single time you push something
onto the Python stack you can have a
trigger that's exactly what I wanted for
a read watch and so I added this it was
actually a fairly simple exercise to
just add some code to trigger something
now the really wild thing is here I have
a a patched C Python interpreter and yet
in the demo that I gave during the
lightening talk I didn't I showed you
that there were no tricks up my sleeve
and what I showed you was this demo
working for an unpatched C Python
interpreter for a C Python chopper that
I built from source and had molested in
no way whatsoever all I did was pip
install a module and the deeper question
is how do you pip install patches to an
interpreter it turns out it's very easy
and it's a little technique that I
cooked up earlier this year so I have a
version of this where I have a let's go
in to sideload where I have a side
loadable version and an aside loadable
version we have our sitar Watch module
and you can see it adds some stuff to
the Syst module here and you can see
here what I do is I hook PI eval eval
frame X and it turns out it's actually
really easy to just go into a c function
in linux or mac and just add a
trampoline and swap out c functions and
by this mechanism what I can do is I can
arbitrarily distribute or I can
distribute arbitrary changes to a c
python interpreter in a form that you
can just pip install so there's a couple
of things that I've shown in previous
talks and previous lightning talks where
I added features to Python right try it
experimenting with things and I always
thought the standard for how people
judge these or the standard for how
these things enter into the into C
Python itself into you know the project
itself is that people write a pep and
they argue about it for months and
months and months and then somebody
eventually has to write some
implementation
they argue about that for months and
months and months and at some point
something gets done and I thought it'd
be much more much more interesting if
you could just go and write a feature
that did anything at all added any kind
of feature whatsoever to cpython
and you could make it pip installable by
anybody out there get a bunch of users
and then short-circuit some of the
discussion that said you can see this is
an enormous this is absolutely the most
gratuitous demo I have and it's the
reason why I came up with this I wanted
to see what the worst thing I could
possibly do with cpython loss I think
the demo I showed you during lightning
talks where I do a read watch on the
number one and return to so when I add
one plus one it gives you four and when
I assign it to a variable I do one plus
one and it gives you X you want to see
that again I can't show that to you
again
now it's neat so that's easy just do a
watch and the watch is a frame object
and you say if is instance object and
int and the int is between zero and ten
the return this times two otherwise you
return the object and then you just pull
from collections a default ticked and
you set an hour assistant set or watch
and you just do a default dict where you
always return this watch object and now
the number one becomes a number two if I
sign this and I try and add it to itself
one plus one is now eight and you can
really give somebody a very bad day and
we can see you can do all sorts of crazy
things with this who knows what's
happening here
this is gratuitous this is supposed to
provoke you that said I decided for this
talk to instead of going in the
direction of the avant-garde to go in
the direction of the postmodern I'm
afraid I was afraid I was putting
together the slides for this that even
if the demos didn't fail and I didn't
have egg on my face
the this would be a little bit too high
concept for you so bear with me but
there is a point the question that I'm
posing you for this talk is does code
quality matter and the answer for that I
can give you right now if you're here
and you're trying to watch a talk about
does code quality matter you already
know the answer which is no it doesn't
you wouldn't come to this talk if you
thought code quality mattered you'd only
come if you didn't think it mattered and
you want somebody to back you up on that
so the answer is no code quality doesn't
matter we're done because a lot of
people are going to come and see this
or view it on YouTube and they're gonna
be asking this question does code
quality matter and they can ask they're
gonna be asking themselves things like
do I really need to learn Python that
well do I need to know Python well
enough to understand the crazy code that
he put on the screen just there or any
the see stuff and the answer is no if
you're asking that question the answer
is probably no so what's the point why
am I even bothering why am I here
I asked that question to myself all the
time and it's not because I'm
existential but because I'm trying to
give you a good talk so I'll tell you
about the process this is the secret
this talk is a total bait and switch by
the way I'll tell you the process of how
people give talks how normal people give
talks how you get into speaking if you
are somebody who wrote scikit-learn or
in the audience matplotlib or do have
any other core developers and projects
in the audience we have Brett cannon who
did see who does don't be doing Python
for 12 years if you're one of those
people you've already made it you don't
have to worry about getting it you don't
have to worry about profile you have to
worry about giving cool talks and people
will link to your already famous you can
just give talks about that project until
you're dead and you'll be exactly Tom
Tom Caswell is in the audience he's
giving a lightning talk today what are
you giving it are you gonna be lightning
talk on is it matplotlib oh it is okay
okay very good
does it work with matplotlib okay
they're very good very good so you can
see you've already made it if you're
like me what you do is you fight you
start by talking about something
somebody else did the reason you do that
is it's an easy pitch to a conference
you say I'm gonna talk about something
that somebody else did and as long as I
read through the documentation and the
blog post and the Stack Overflow
questions well enough you can be pretty
certain dat as long as i'm an energetic
personality you can be certain that the
talk will be okay and that's exactly how
I started in talking my very first
conference talk was in PI Gotham was at
PI Gotham 2012 and I talked about
decorators and context managers and I
just explained to the audience how they
worked and the only prep that I needed
was reading through the documentation
about decorators and context managers
and coming up with some demos and some
slides and it was very easy since then
I've given I counted last night I think
51 talks at 30-something conferences so
it's been a lot and I'll show you the
next step that you do once you do that
you say well I don't want to keep
talking about somebody else's work I
want to start talking about my own work
so you talk about some small library or
some tool that you worked on or if you
don't have an open source library worked
on or some tool or something you've
built at work you talk about some not
quite totally mainstream approach to a
common problem so you say well here's a
problem we have in data munging or
here's an approach that people aren't
using correctly in that a visualization
exactly what I did I started talking
about generators and if any of you have
attended any of the past Python events
for about a year there I gave a lot of
talks about generators and different
ways you could conceptualize them
different ways you could model code with
them it's the standard practice then the
third phase is you talk about your
opinions and you try and talk about some
controversial ideas and there's some
message I gave my my second or third
keynote ever at PI Texas earlier this
year and I was going to give a version
of I talked talking about that did you
this other project that I worked on this
really small hacky thing and I thought
well I can't just go up in front of a
bunch of people and show them some weird
hacks I have to have a message so you
have to go there and that's kind of
where we are right now so there's some
message here buried under the layers of
meta and crazy cpython hacks the most
important thing is this step is not then
you get famous the step is it doesn't
work unless you already have become
famous and this is something that a lot
of you may not realize and it's very
interesting what happens is when you're
famous you have more bandwidth to
communicate to people so I've been
giving these kind of talks for a while
and one difficulty is when you when
you're famous you have a certain amount
of bandwidth so you can write a
one-liner somewhere and people will pour
over that you'll try and understand all
the nuances and all the depth of it and
when you're not famous and by the way
you do not want to be famous there's a
certain obligation that comes to fame
it's not something that you want but
when you do get famous you and you have
to be like Drake famous not like Guido
famous you have to be like super famous
you end you could and even in those
situations you could end up like Leslie
Lamport who knows the story of Leslie
Lamport and Paxos in 1989 Leslie Lamport
who is already a seminal figure in
computer science
publish the paper or tried to publish a
paper on a distributed a solution to the
Consensus problem in distributed
algorithms called paxos and he had
surrounded it with the same humorous
trappings as he had another topic that
he had made very famous the two generals
problem or the Byzantine generals
problem and the paper was rejected they
said we don't want this jokey trash he
put it in his in his filing cabinet he
sent it to some of his friends and then
six months later asked them do you know
a novel approach a novel solution to the
Consensus problem and they all said no
and he put it in his he put her in his
filing cabinet and about eight years
later when there was more desire for a
solution to these problems he took it
out of his filing cabinet and
republished it and it turns out that
Paxos is one of the I would say it's one
of the most it's one of the most
exciting and one of the seminal
developments in all of this distributed
algorithms and it took him eight years
for anybody to notice it so you do have
to be famous for this to work so if you
come away from this talk having no idea
what happened don't worry I won't be
offended however an easy way to fame is
controversy so I thought how do I give
the best talk I'll talk about something
that everybody has an opinion on like
does code quality matter so it turns out
you've seen this talk before in fact
you've seen this talk twice and not for
me but from other people you've seen
somebody say does code quality matter
and they told you yes of course it
matters and they probably show you
something that in order if you need
scalability or anytime to market or
rather if you need to scale up these
slides are a little bit swapped if you
need scalability or if you need solve
really hard problems then coal quality
really matters and you've also seen this
talk before and somebody said no and
they said something like well it doesn't
really matter if the code is good or bad
what most important is time to market
user experience you know the code is
just what we tell those trolls in the
cave to do in order to make our
customers happy so you've seen this talk
before and they've given wildly
different answers unfortunately when
you've seen this talk before it probably
wasn't even about core quality it
probably was about something else
entirely and I hate to say this and it's
gonna be very controversial but
sometimes when you've seen this talk
before you've seen a correlation between
the speaker and the answer they've given
so if somebody comes up to stage and
they say well I
really really good at writing good code
and code ecology matters and then
somebody comes up on stage and they say
you know I've dabbled a little bit here
and there but I'm a really good product
person and user experience person and it
turns out that's more important it turns
out for everybody in the world what's
most important in the world also happens
to be what they're good at so that may
hint at you a certain bias for where
this talk is going because you know I
know a couple of things about Python
most of these talks are about selling
some agenda that code quality is just a
prop for selling that agenda for saying
user experience is important
colloidosome matters
it was meant to provoke human to get you
to start thinking about the issue but it
wasn't really about coke quality and I
would say the reason for that is and as
you'll see this is an issue that we need
to deconstruct now I'll say the
avant-garde is not controversial the
stuff that I showed you before and some
of these wild things I can do with
Python I always thought those would be
very controversial which is why I
surrounded myself with this verbiage of
don't use this code I thought I'm going
to show you something really weird you
can do in Python I'm going to show you
you know the best memorizing you can
write if you look at my github there's
or if you look at the gist on github of
that have I have all these little code
samples of really neat things you could
do that require a little bit of you
require a lot of thought and a lot of
parsing in order to understand what they
do but that's not actually controversial
I've never had anybody come up to me and
say I hated what you do you know this is
nobody cares about that kind of code
never ever had that happen I thought I
would which is why you know my email
address is James that don't use this
code comm I posted some of this stuff on
a blog at seriously don't use code comm
you know my twitter handle is well on on
IRC I'm D UTC for don't use this code
and also because I didn't want a really
long one and when that one's taken cuz
every so often you know you get a net
split or something and your IRC handles
taken I fall back onto D you TCH for
don't use this code Hass I'm from Texas
it's not controversial the only time
I've ever had anybody yell at me after a
talk is when I talked about Python 2
versus 3 and I said all I said I
seriously all I said was Python 3 is
where a lot of the effort for the core
developers is going and if you're able
to use Python 3 there's a lot of neat
features in it and I had somebody harass
me for 45 minutes at a bar about Python
2
as Python three and white code doesn't
matter and I was shocked I wanna I want
to set aside and before we can even talk
about code quality I want to discuss
with you the important question of what
is good code so who here in the audience
has ever seen good code in their life
who here in the audience has seen bad
code who here in the audience works with
data scientists yeah and all of you have
seen bad code too huh
I know in the original version of these
slides I actually named dropped a couple
of libraries that we all know are not
that great but who here thinks they know
what good code is who has some metric
does it involve elegance
does it involve understandability I'm
sure you all have some metric that you
use and it turns out all of your metrics
can be described in one very easy very
simple way oops
good code is code that I wrote and bad
code is code that you wrote and every
single time I've ever ever ever heard
anybody talk about good code it's always
good code is code good code is this code
and also that's the code I wrote and bad
code is the code that you wrote for
example unnecessarily complicated code
is the code you wrote the code that
covers all the complex special cases and
make sure to really solve the problem
fundamentally that's the code I wrote
this the code that's so self-indulgent
and over-engineered that's the code you
wrote but the code that scales and
adapts the problems that we're gonna see
in five months that we don't even know
that's the code I wrote every single
time this topic comes up it's like an
interview every time you go to interview
for a position the questions you're
gonna be asked are the questions which
make you look the most like the
interviewer so if that person is a
really good programmer they can ask you
programming questions if they're not
that comfortable their programming
skills they'll ask you the more
important questions which are whatever
they're good at we see a lot of
ourselves in this problem so here's the
here's a question does quote quality
matter the real answer to it is go away
just go away don't ask the question it's
pointless
every time you ask the question you're
going to be pushed towards one of these
two extremes and you're not gonna be
able answer but that would be a really
lame talk if I said if I just spent 25
minutes of your time telling you no
there's no answer there
is an answer to this and the answer to
this is we need to deconstruct the
question if we really care about Co
quality if we really care about
understanding weather code quality
matters or not we need to actually have
some semi formal way to talk about code
quality to talk about what it is when
we're writing code to really analyze
where it might matter or not matter
because we've seen and the different
talks on this topic we've seen sometimes
people say code quality doesn't matter
and they have very good reasons for it
they say my startup could never have
succeeded unless we made the right
investments into these technologies we
would never have scaled to 20 billion
users that's not quite correct we would
never a scale to so many users with only
17 employees or some people say well you
know what we pivoted 10 times and the
eventual market that we found was
something that wasn't even related to
the first thing that we were doing the
co quality of those first 19 approaches
it doesn't matter what matters is
execution time and they're right as well
so it's clear that we can construct a
scenario in which code quality does
matter and we can construct a new
scenario in which code quality does not
matter and if I were to tell you well
code quality matters when it does and it
doesn't matter when it doesn't
that would be useless it'd start
illogical unfortunately this question is
useless as it's specified and we need to
find a better way to think about this
this is the talk that I've been trying
to give all year which is how do we how
do we encourage better ways of
conceptualizing topics that are
important to us as software developers I
did some of my background some of my
degree you know when I did my
undergraduate I did it in liberal arts
and one of the topics that I covered was
comparative literature and literary
analysis and it's something that you
know we all make fun of casually you all
think that you know you can sit in a
literary class and somebody asked what
was the author thinking you can just BS
whatever you want and that'll be
accepted but it turns out that that's a
very difficult field and you need to
build some very abstract and oolitic 'el
tools to be able to effectively analyze
something as simple as a poem or a
literary work and derive any meaning
from that and one of these tools are
given some of these tools are given to
us by these different frameworks in
literary analysis structuralism
post-structuralism modernism
post-modernism and post modernist gives
some very interesting tools about taking
questions that on face looked like to go
in both directions and instead of
answering them by choosing yes or no by
finding a middle path where we question
the question itself where we deconstruct
a question now I do want to make since I
have time I do want to make a slight
comment on this aside here this is a
total rant but I have the time for it
and frankly what are you gonna do right
I mean I'm on stage I have the mic come
on
benchmarks earlier this year I was at
Julia Khan which was a fantastic event
Julia is an amazing language has come up
in the last two or three years it's an
unfocused supportive project it is a
fantastic tool if you're an AR user or
if you're interested in machine learning
or data science at that event one of the
things that every single speaker wanted
to show off about Julia was benchmarks
and it turned out that all the speakers
were statisticians and they would come
up onstage and say well look this is a
thousand times faster and then I have
one slide with the 1000 X or let's say
look this is 23 times faster than have a
slide 23 X or they even have a graph not
a single slide ever said was this the
average the median the variance the
standard deviation and I thought you're
all statisticians and if I came to you
on your topic of interest and I told you
well the answer is three I don't even
tell you I didn't even give you a model
you would throw me out of the room and
yet four benchmarks we're allowed to do
it and it's very interesting because I
thought you know if you have a thousand
times speed-up there's probably
something there maybe if you have a two
and a half times speed up our
statisticians gonna tell you how do you
even we won't get into the null
hypothesis right baguette but how do you
even validate that how do you even
validate that there's something there
and so benchmarks that's my mini rant
this this is look look how many topics
were covering this talk this is amazing
we got some real good density of content
here but it it's useless that that said
that that said that doesn't mean that we
can never talk about benchmark said we
can never talk about optimization but we
have to be more careful or more delicate
about how we talk about them we have to
talk about the model behind them and the
purpose of this talk is to try and give
you some model under which we can talk
about this I won't give you the only
model but I'll give you one model that I
use to think about these so in in in
order to preface this model I'd like to
say that most of the time the code that
we write is some
artifact of some business process we're
at PI data here a lot of us are data
scientists and we're writing code to
supplement some business that exists
somewhere we're not writing code for our
own personal pleasure we're not writing
as an artistic endeavor there are people
in the world who do write code in that
fashion but for the most part we're
doing it as part of our job and I think
that a lot of the time some of the
disagreement that we have about how code
should be written doesn't really account
for most programmers who are writing
code in a professional environment are
trying their best to solve some problem
in that professional environment they're
trying their best to supplement some
business process with that code and that
they do deserve a little bit of the
benefit of the doubt we shouldn't just
bandy about things like you're
overcomplicating it there may be a
reason why the code was written that way
we should be a little bit more sensitive
about asking what these reasons might be
that said I will say in these
environments there always exists some
business process and that business
process is amenable to automation or
it's amenable to mechanization and you
could think in traditional manufacturing
technology is all about mechanization
you take something that a human being
would do and you do it better with the
Machine you can do it more accurately
you can do it faster and this exists in
the software world as well there's some
process something that a human being is
doing that the computer can do more
accurately or faster or even in some
cases there's a tension between the two
of them the computer can do it less
accurately but faster or the computer
into it more accurately but slower and
we could see that's that's a very common
description for much of the work that we
do we take that problem somebody
described it to us they say well I have
this particular problem and I don't want
all of my I don't want to have 50
analysts you know building these reports
every day I'd rather have one machine
that builds a reports takes all the data
in normalizes it and builds a report and
so when we look at that we say how do we
model this problem and this is one area
which I feel in professional situations
we put almost no effort into the actual
process of understanding the model for
the problem we're trying to solve
because it turns out and I've seen this
happen so many times it turns out that
the world has in in the words of some
postmodern theorists has an infinite
profundity the degrees of freedom in the
world and when you're
especially when you're trying to solve a
human problem a problem created by human
beings have an infinite degrees of
freedom so some of these problems that
we run into our localization right how
many times have you tried have found a
very simple solution to a problem that
assumed you know that each element of a
string is a letter and that things could
capitalize in a consistent fashion
or how about date/time processing that
you assume that you know one time comes
before the other because they're
lexicographically ordered or that you
assume things like you know there's no
random gaps in date times or that you
can't add seconds here or add seconds
there a lot of the times the problems
that we're solving are human problems
and so they're completely unconstrained
by any logic or any reason and this is
an enormous number of the problems were
trying to solve how many people have
tried to build a billing system or you
know in the 90s the typical project was
here let's build a payroll system and
they suddenly realize that it's possible
for you to have cycles in a payroll
system where somebody's boss is their
own boss or you can have all sorts of
undefined behaviors and it doesn't bug
the human beings who created that system
but it makes for an infinite complexity
for the people who are trying to program
some solution to automate that system
what we see is that we always have to
have some model and that model always
has to reduce the amount of information
that can be expressed in the real world
system so we take some very complex
business problem and we say we can cut
we can with a set of assumption that a
set of axioms we can handle some subset
of this in some reliable fashion that is
tractable we can actually within our
lifetimes write the code to solve this
once we do that we encode that model in
a programming language now it turns out
that there are many layers of models and
I would think that I'll give you an
example for how this works when I was
working in finance actually I still work
in finance but I was working at big bank
finance we worked on a lot of projects
building large systems for trading desks
I worked I always worked for the front
office and I was always working attached
to a trading desk we had to build some
system and it turned out in that
circumstance somebody was being paid
money to pick up the phone and buy and
sell things why they were being paid
money I don't know but that was the
business problem that we had and our
goal was to automate that to apply
computers to do something to the human
beings camped and one very easy
dimension of that then we could automate
was a
your mortgage desk and you're trading a
million things a day there is no way
that somebody can have on a piece of
paper a list of all the things you
traded and the profit or loss that you
made and it's a very it's a seemingly
simple problem for a human being to
delegate that work to a computer which
can process data in that form where it's
mostly fairly regular and it's a fairly
reasonable thing that you could say well
in order to supplement this business
process I need to have some reporting
mechanism to do positions P&L and risk
that facilitates the business process
you hand that off to your development
team and they go wild but in order to do
that you have to make some simplifying
assumptions and these simplifying
assumptions are almost always wrong and
over the course of a trading system that
might last for ten years each area where
these are wrong will always show up so
an example from my career is we once had
a system and it assumed that fixed
income instruments settled in one
currency so if you bought something in
USD it would settle in USD so you're
sorry if you bought if you bought some
instrument and you paid American dollars
that was the end of it and when it
matured you'd get American dollars back
and only about two or three years in we
suddenly had some situations where you
buy something in American dollars and it
would settle in three currencies so you
get a little bit of Canadian dollars a
little bit of Japanese yen and a little
bit of US Dollars and it completely
broke the models that we had because we
had some assumptions there there are
other assumptions that we typically make
that seem very reasonable so another one
was the market value of a position is
equal to how much you hold of it and how
much a unit quantity is worth and that
almost every trade system I've seen
makes that assumption the market value
is equal to the market price times the
volume but there's an assumption there
it's an assumption of linearity and at
one point I had an opportunity to work
on a desk that traded a very illiquid
instrument it was a mortgage instrument
and the more of it you bought the price
changed so there was no longer a linear
relationship between the market value
and the amount that you held it may be
that if you held a lot of it the price
went up corresponding to that as you
started to trade towards the extent the
extent of the liquidity and all of these
assumptions were never spoken about and
never acknowledged and they were so core
to the system that we were building that
the moment we had a problem that broke
this it would break the system we'd have
to have some very
Nyack's and I feel that the problem here
was that we failed to acknowledge up
front some of the assumptions we were
making we failed to acknowledge the
model that we had and we failed to say
to some business leader that the system
that we built made these assumptions if
if the circumstances have changed and
these are some just no longer valid we
may not be able to use the system or we
need some acknowledgement this system is
no longer applicable now the solution to
this and the last step just for
completeness is that we encode this in
Python and we may encode it using
embedded DSL so for example in the case
of pricing a portfolio one thing we
might realize is we have many
instruments in our portfolio and they
may repeat so you might have CD s and CD
s are bilateral contracts and so each CD
S is kind of unique except they're
standardized and so given the same
parameters for the CD s the pricing
should come out the same given the same
recovery rate given the same survival
curve it should come out the same and so
you can avoid a lot of redundant
computations by building this as a graph
and doing computations only for unique
instruments however you decided to
define instruments and you might build a
graph yourself and all of these big
trading systems have some graph
components somewhere and the ways that
you encode this graph component can be
wildly different so there are some large
organizations where they build this
graph as part of the modeling software
themselves every instrument that they
trade whether a bond or a CD f's will
have some price method and that price
method will call some other method we'll
call some other method and the actual
method chains in the software will be
built into a graph that is then that you
apply some algorithms to to cache and
one up another organization I worked at
it was completely different everything
was built off of a price and so the
price of something was just you pull
some curve that represents its price and
then behind the scenes there was a graph
that would tell you if you change this
curve in this way it triggers a change
here that was a graph is a graph built
in XML and it would it would represent
the derivation rules for how a bump to a
survival curve changes something over
here it was exactly the same model but
it was encoded in a very different way
and everything that one piece of
software could do despite looking very
different the other piece of software
they could do the exact same things and
have the exact same restrictions but the
encoding was different
I think that in many cases the different
encodings that we see amount to spelling
they amount to you know we have some
Canadians in the audience who have been
gracious enough to join us and there are
cases in which Canadians but and we have
an Australia in the audience as well so
there are there are situations where
Australians and Canadians spell things a
little bit differently than Americans
and there could be an argument as to
whether this is a better or worse
spelling but for the most part it's just
a different spelling there's really no
unless somebody in the audience really
wants to object are you or no you
doesn't matter too much for a lot of
dynamic languages and especially for
languages orientate around protocols
these different encodings these
different spellings don't really matter
that much so you can already see that
we're getting a much richer answer to
our question does code quality matter
well well I'll show you an example of
this and so this is a common example in
Python Python is a very protocol based
language and you can see you know people
go wild about generators and I gave so
many talks about generators and you
could see you could write a generating
this way and generate this way there's
some subtle differences between the two
but there were only real difference
between the two of these is notational
or I'd say the most major difference
being the two of these is notational and
these two different spellings for the
same concept you could swap you could
probably swap one for the other and it
wouldn't make that much of a difference
it turns out that this deconstruction of
the question I think gives us a much
richer answer to the question that is if
you're asking about code quality in the
case of how do I spell this thing well
once you've once you've restricted
yourself to answering at that level you
can often make a very specific complaint
about the code you can say well I'd
rather do this because it's notationally
simpler it's less code it's easier to
read and if you understand what a
generator is that's fine and it does
require that maybe some newbies on your
team who don't know what generators are
might have to learn what generators are
and they might have to go beyond what
you know some very basic Python that
they may have learned oh you could make
an argument for this and you can say
well I don't really wanna make an
argument this but but you could you
could you could potentially and you can
make a very target and very specific
argument that's better than well I wrote
this one and go away versus you wrote
this one and I don't want to know what a
generator is I don't have I don't want
to have to know that
this is the point of this talk how do we
talk about code how can how can we
answer the question of whether code
quality matters in a richer fashion how
can we build a framework for thinking
about this or we can answer this in a
very specific fashion so it's totally
tautological to just say well sometimes
the matter sometimes it doesn't
instead with some framework we can we
can answer these questions more
specifically so for example in the case
where you say coke Ollie definitely
matters without the right code quality
my start-up couldn't have scaled to the
millions and millions of users they have
without having to hire lots of people
well maybe that's a code quality issue
that's not in terms of the spelling or
the encoding in the programming language
but it's a code quality issue in terms
of the fundamental modeling maybe
somewhere along the way somebody who
made the right ones you say you're
building a platform like Twitter you can
think very easily that the right model
for how messages move within that
platform can lead to something that can
scale very nicely and the wrong way for
modeling that can lead to something that
can scale very poorly we even see this
in programming language themselves
certain models for programming languages
lead to languages that are very easy to
optimize and certain programming models
for languages lead to languages that are
not very easy to optimize and at that
level you could definitely say well the
code quality does or does not matter
definitely if you go one level higher
and you talk about the business problem
if you don't have a business problem
then you know what you know whatever you
do it's the weekends have fun if you do
have a business problem and the business
problem is get this get this code out
say you work at a company like Microsoft
and the thing is get version one out as
soon as you possibly can no matter how
good or bad it is then the end the
questions already answered for you we
have some people from Microsoft in the
audience or if the problem is you know
we're building something that's very
important that's safety critical then
you can see the right framework for
thing yet about the problem can actually
lead you to the answer much better than
I think the way that we typically
discuss things like code quality now I
will say that the model that I've given
you involves a little bit of sleight of
hand
I don't like sleight of hand even though
you can see it here because there's a
lot of presumptions for example I
presume certain things about the model
existing and the model leading to rather
that the business problem exists in a
certain fashion and it leads to a model
a certain fashion if you look
you think very carefully and kind of
slice and dice the model I've given you
or at least the framework I've given you
can see a couple of ways where I've made
presumptions and then answered it with
that presumption that said the purpose
of this talk is not to get famous it's
not to be controversial it's not to be
avantgarde but it's to give you a little
dose of post-modernism to imbue a little
bit more meaning and a little bit more
thoughtfulness and to this very
fundamental question of whether quality
matters or not now one thing I never
asked are never presented to you was
whether or not the question itself is
important and I think that by virtue of
you all being here on Wednesday at 324
p.m. it's probably important enough for
you unless the talks in the room kind of
stink but I think they're great so it's
probably a pretty important question I
will say that here you can see this is
maybe at least one of my clearest
postmodern talks I add a little bit of a
bond card in the beginning because I
really hate giving talks I don't have
any code involved in them that was the
that was just an excuse but I hope
you've enjoyed this and this is
something where I'm very passionate
about so if somebody asks you does code
quality matter you can say yes certain a
coatings are notation better than others
you can say yes certain coatings proved
to be poorly compatible with other
coatings you can say yes certain
coatings are redundant you can answer
very specific questions and you can
answer them given some framework for
what does it mean to write code I hope
you've enjoyed this talk I hope it's
given you something to tweet about or
tumblr about or Pinterest about or I
don't know what periscope is I do know
that tinder is it you can tinder about
this so so if you're like hey what are
you doing tonight you could say oh I'm
thinking about a talk that I saw up high
data that is appropriate you can do that
but I hope you've enjoyed it
I'm James Powell thank you very much
what do people have nobody asked
questions nobody ever has questions for
talks okay
okay okay come on time up shut up yeah
yeah but that's not right right I mean
there's actually many different ways to
do things I think well I think what that
means is give it give it give so I think
I think I think actually given a
specific model for the pond they're
trying to solve there often is one
obvious way so one common thing is let's
say we're doing something manipulating
paths on a system right the way that we
typically do it is we might do it with
just a string and you say you want to
split up the components of a path you
take a string and do dot split on a
sledge and that's the one right way to
do it if you're able to make the
assumption that a path is just a string
of characters with a slash in it right
and then when you make that problem more
sophisticated you say well actually I
want to work on other platforms which
they don't have a slash going in the
same direction you might make a more
sophisticated approach and say okay I'm
use oh s dot path or path Lib or
something like that
so for the different layers of the types
of problems I think Python is very nice
at giving you a way to solve it with
that assumption there was a there was a
conversation in the hallway earlier
about strings in Python and you could
say for certain ways that you think
about strings in Python the built in
string might be appropriate if you think
about it as some you know sequence of
characters that you manipulate in a
particular fashion
just regular strings are enough if you
need to think about them in a slightly
more sophisticated fashion maybe you
need to start introducing your own
string library or own library there but
target it on some model where you where
you have knowledge of how simple of the
problems I want to solve how easily do I
want to solve it and I'll say that if
you ever if you ever sit in any of the
classes I gave it to a lot of corporate
training you'll see that in the way that
we present the examples will always
present the example with the simplest
approach first and there's usually one
right way to do it and then we'll say
well consider this this and this corner
cases that expands the problem you're
trying to solve and also expands the
code Mike
like cyclomatic complexity I can I could
never actually figure out how to take
coma graph and actually relate coma
graph to cyclomatic complexity like
you're just trying to so I will say this
I think that I had I had an opportunity
to look over a lot of metrics for
software quality that I don't think
anybody actually uses in practice things
like measuring definition use pairs
looking at you know definition clear
paths some formalizations I had a
textbook that I was going through and
nobody seems to ever do that but I
thought these might be interesting
guiding you know interesting ways for us
to guide or add a little bit of
additional information I think one big
problem that we have by the way code
reviews are garbage
most code reviews are most code reviews
are just people expressing their own
political will right like I like you so
go ahead and our I don't like you or and
don't go ahead and I think that as you
start to do things like add metrics to
that you get over focused on the metric
I think the only way to do a code review
is when both parties are equally
invested in the code actually working
and being in production and also being
completed so it's not just keep
submitting me the code review until you
guess what I want but some who has
anyone ever had the situation just keep
submitting the code to me until I have
until you're able to guess exactly what
I'm looking for even even incorporate on
developer right these could be guiding
forces but it's very important to not
let them lead you astray
other questions now this is the best
question answer ever had I need to give
more so
within the degrees of freedom that
grammar provides you write publication
has this for the longest time the
various parts have had style manual you
know the rest of the universe do it you
will but for our purposes for what we do
and how we think about things you know I
I think that's a fantastic and very
specific question one thing that I'm
personally very averse to is talking
about computer languages in the same way
we talk about human languages I think
human languages are a lot richer and a
lot more complicated than programming
languages are even though sometimes we
can talk about fluency and both and
things like that I feel we're
underselling
human language that said that said pep 8
everybody loves to like install flake
eight and say oh this is not Pepe
compliant but the thing is in my view
pep eight is how you want to write code
to satisfy somebody who's approving your
code that's part of the C Python
standard library approval or code review
mechanism and so I agree for things like
coding standards coding standards is if
you're an engineer your job as an
engineer is to subordinate yourself to
some higher purpose some business
objective right so I have my own way of
writing code I don't use spaces what
intent this commotion came up during
PyCon Canada during one of the keynote
somebody asked who uses to space and
uses for spaces in my own code I use
taps
tabs for indentation and spaces for
alignment but if I were to submit a
patch to see Python I would do exactly
what I see around me because I care more
about getting the patch in than the
specifics and so something like a style
guide I think is a very appropriate way
to draw the boundaries for we know you
have your own opinions we know you're an
individual but this is what we've
decided commonly as the way to do things
other questions
Aaron
if you're designing an API you mean the
the quality of the API or the
discoverability mm-hmm so CPC Python is
a perfect example of this the C Python
source code is very easy to read through
and understand yes but what I think what
you see in practice is a data scientist
will look at a program exercise and they
don't care about it it's not like they
don't want the code to be good
it's just that they care more about the
thing that they do which is data science
and a programmer like a data science
will say well who cares if the code
sucks at least it works we'll just get
some programmers to fix it up and a
programmer will look at the code and
we'll look at look at the same project
and say well the code so it's most
important the data science I just pull
out of a book I just from scikit-learn
import model model train and I'm done
right and so there is this contention
between the two of them but I don't
think that one side is necessarily right
or wrong I think there's some very
unexplored assumptions behind the two
you're right in some specific cases
though when you're talking about things
like ap is then the design of the API
matters but I would say that if you're
talking about things like Python for
humans and api's like that just as
important as the way that the API looks
the way the function calls are named is
the fundamental model the API exposes
which i think is something that people
consistently ignore because who here has
worked at some organization where you
had many different asset masters or
corporate act corporate actions
databases and somebody said well can't
we have one central repository for all
the things that can happen to a company
and you just query it and there turns
out there's some very large information
companies
in the finance industry that are trying
to build like one standard corporate
actions database for this company split
into these companies in this fashion but
what they seem to fail to realize is the
way that we want to deal with that
information or tractable fashion is
usually specialized to a problem we want
to solve and so the reason we have this
proliferation of these different asset
masters is that sometimes what we
consider to be a fungible asset is
different sometimes the fundamental
model of what we talk about is different
sometimes to bilateral contracts with
the exact same terms are the same for
example in the case of pricing and other
times they're different if you're
looking at them in terms of different
position line items so api's I think the
API problem is a lot more subtle than
just did you use a decorator rather than
wrap it yourself or did you use four
spaces I think we're out of time but I'm
I'm glad that you enjoyed my talk I
really enjoyed presenting and please
stick around for lightning talks we have
we have some really good lightning talks
thank you so much
you